[Musica]
o un'importante rivelazione da
sì
io sono iron man
ahimè non sono iron man ma sono qui per
parlarvi di un superpotere che abbiamo
tutti noi ben nascosto agli occhi ma che
ci caratterizza più della nostra faccia
la voce è un fenomeno sonoro acustico
che viene sprigionato dalle corde vocali
ma che interessa molti organi del nostro
corpo che hanno funzioni ben diverse
i polmoni i muscoli le cartilagini le
ossa
tutti questi organi assieme alle
caratteristiche particolari acustiche
del nostro corpo si sono specializzati
in modo estremo per produrre la voce
voglio raccontarvi la storia della voce
inizialmente era come quella degli
animali libera ed emotiva seducente e
sperimentale straordinariamente capace
di imitare come in un bambino così vasta
era la capacità di produrre suoni e
della voce lo è ancora naturalmente che
ha permesso di determinare il linguaggio
ovvero una tecnologia straordinaria con
cui l'uomo e la voce hanno iniziato a
trasmettere informazioni conoscenze
esperienze e di fatto hanno trasmesso
culture e tutto ciò che ne consegue nel
mondo
inizialmente la diffusione della cultura
è stata orale poi è arrivata la
scrittura ma questa storia d'amore tra
linguaggio e voce ai un certo senso
privilegiato il linguaggio è ingabbiato
la voce il linguaggio figlio della voce
appunto è una tecnologia straordinaria
ma per riuscire in questa impresa a
l'uomo ha selezionato dei suoni
particolari i suoni utili alle lingue
giusti per le lingue ma ha tralasciato
una cosa fondamentale della voce ovvero
la capacità di trasmettere emozioni
voglio farvi un esempio avete presente
il bambino lui piange
ho fame o sonno o sete ed è sempre
chiarissimo perché la voce a questa
immediatezza emotiva mentre il
linguaggio è in un certo senso mediato
dalla parola e l'uomo ha sempre amato
cantare perché la voce anche canto per
quanto il canto stesso sia stato
condizionato dalle regole del linguaggio
l'uomo non è mai riuscito o non ha mai
voluto liberarsi dell'incanto che la
voce suscitava ad esempio provate a
pensare alle acustiche dei monasteri che
suscitava la voce per lo spettatore che
gli permetteva di raggiungere di vino
più delle parole utilizzate faceva
vibrare proprio per favorire questa cosa
sapete sono stati rinvenuti all'interno
all'interno delle mura dei monasteri dei
trucchetti proprio specifici per
perfezionare l'acustica hanno installato
delle anfore che selezionavano alcuni
tipi di frequenza proprio quelli utili
alla alla diffusione della voce e il
canto ha avuto un'evoluzione
straordinaria nella sua tecnica nei
secoli però anche in questo caso c'è
stato un condizionamento di tipo
estetico
ovvero se noi pensiamo al canto per
eccellenza
è il canto lirico e anche chiamato il
bel canto proprio perché sono stati
selezionati suoni più belli a danno di
quelli brutti
però così veri dobbiamo aspettare il
novecento per essere scossi come rock
come vuole il rock nelle regole e nelle
convenzioni anche in questo senso
abbiamo avuto delle figure straordinarie
ad esempio c'è stato il dadaista kurt
schwitters che ho scritto queste urso
nate in urla ten che sono è un poema
vocalico davvero di di mont rose ruanda
e se di fatto liberato del linguaggio
sono arrivati poi i futuristi e i loro
hanno introdotto l'utilizzo delle
onomatopee esistevano anche prima ballo
lo hanno fatto un uso massiccio quindi
parole che esprimevano nel proprio senso
il suono che facevano quindi drin drin
twink lars boom
poi è arrivato antonin artaud ha fatto
un sacco di rivoluzioni artoni e il
teatro ma nell'uso della voce le sue
performance vocali erano inaudite
estremamente emotive sono tanti gli
esempi da fare voglio sicuramente
ricordare john cage che nella sua
operazione di liberare la musica e
l'utilizzo dei suoni dai pregiudizi di
fatto ha aperto la strada in molte
direzioni compresa la voce ed è stato
demetrio stratos che ha fatto tesoro di
questa lezione e ha riscoperto molte
delle capacità vocali anche studiando
dalla sua grande maestra ovvero la sua
figlia neonata
anastasia perché dalle narrazioni e
dalle sperimentazioni che un bambino fa
per limitando gli adulti per imparare a
farsi capire
nasce la sua capacità di esprimersi
perché la voce è imitazione
la voce è mimesis allora nel mondo
ci sono ci sono delle tecniche
straordinarie che permettono alla voce
di fare cose incredibili
certo di suscitare emozioni di
raggiungere sacro limitare i suoni
dell'ambiente degli animali ad esempio
magari vi sarà capitato di sentire
parlare del canto armonico è una tecnica
con cui si possono fare due suoni
contemporaneamente
[Musica]
[Risate]
oppure avrete sentito parlare del canto
dei monaci tibetani il canto come che
utilizzano per la meditazione
[Risate]
sì so che è un po strano però questo
mostro ce l'avete anche voi dentro ha
recentemente non so se qualcuno è
appassionato di game of thrones la voce
dei non morti
ok poi cielo you there are è una cosa
invece molto molto di questi anni molto
recente è la beat box e avete presente
insomma la voce fa tante cose e anche
una medicina ed è un modo che al nostro
corpo per produrre energia può imitare
anche gli strumenti musicali e volevo
proprio invitarvi all'ascolto di questo
esperimento e per farlo
userò una loop station bayern e degli
effetti dei dirigenti che mi permettono
appunto di usando gli stessi effetti che
vengono usati in quegli strumenti del
rock ad esempio di fare una canzone rock
e dovreste conoscerla inizio con la
batteria
[Musica]
qui ok in bound un mostro
vedi time
grazie
la voce un patrimonio di tutti noi la
usiamo per comunicare per comunicarci e
tutti possiamo cantare ci sono certo ci
sarà chi è più dotato e chi meno ma ci
sono un paio di accorgimenti da seguire
per liberare una voce intonata perché
questa magari non ci crederete ma essere
intonati è naturale ma com'è e come
nasce la voce molto di quello che sto
per dirvi lo dobbiamo allo straordinario
lavoro di alfred tomatis la voce non si
vede è nascosta si sente ma cosa
dobbiamo sentire della nostra voce ci
sono due regole fondamentali che
liberano il canto e permettono
soprattutto così come altre cose nella
della nostra fisicità permettono al
corpo di fare il suo lavoro automatico
perché spesso è la testa che lo blocca
queste due regole sono l'attenzione e la
postura
l'attenzione è quella che dobbiamo dare
all'ascolto avviene attraverso le nostre
orecchie ma anche attraverso tutta la
sensibilità del nostro corpo la pelle
pensate l'orecchio è un organo super
tecnologico si forma per primo è già
dopo poche settimane della vita di un
feto è perfettamente operativo è in
grado di fornirci una cosa molto
importante
la prima esperienza sensibile di un
essere vivente che avviene proprio nella
pancia perché così il bambino ha la
possibilità di ambientarsi con i suoni
di riconoscere i suoni dell'ambiente ma
soprattutto di riconoscere i suoni della
voce della madre perché poi quel bambino
nascerà e sono soprattutto fa e provate
a pensare che che trauma sarebbe venire
al mondo senza questa preparazione è
trovarsi all'improvviso appunto in un
mondo di suoni
e sono soprattutto le frequenze più
acute quelle che arrivano al al bambino
al feto perché i suoni vengono filtrati
dal liquido amniotico
queste particolari frequenze stimolano
lo sviluppo dell'encefalo come una vera
e propria corrente di energia neuronale
cioè l'orecchio è di fatto una dinamo
produce energia per garantire questa
straordinaria ed elevata funzione il
corpo umano ha associato la funzione
dell'ascolto che avviene attraverso la
coclea è il nostro sensore che ascolta e
trasforma il suono in impulsi nervosi
assieme a quello dell'equilibrio perché
il nostro sensore accelerometro gps
tutto integrato
si chiama vestibolo e attraverso i suoi
canali semicircolari ha uno scopo
fondamentale la statura eretta del corpo
umano e monitora tutti i movimenti nello
spazio quindi la coclea e il vestibolo
sono fusi insieme nell'orecchio interno
questo perché per garantire la funzione
di ricarica energetica corticale che è
necessaria per lo sviluppo del nostro
cervello l'orecchio ha bisogno di una
posizione molto specifica per sentire
bene tutte le frequenze soprattutto
quelle acute
allora noi dobbiamo parlare della
postura la postura corretta qual è lo
dicevano i nostri maestri a scuole
dritti come un pacchetto no come
un'antenna e vi farò vedere cosa succede
in questo modo allora per avere una
postura corretta è sufficiente diciamo
ruotare un pochino il bacino in avanti
così e allo stesso tempo e allo stesso
tempo avere la sensazione di una corda
che ci tira nella stalla sommità della
testa
ok succedono due cose che vi invito a
osservare le mie costole si alzano e si
aprono e si bloccano quindi l'unico
muscolo che lavorerà sulla respirazione
sarà quello specifico il diaframma
che è uno dei crucci di chi studia canto
eccetera questo muscolo si attiva
automaticamente nel momento in cui noi
abbiamo la postura succede un'altra cosa
fondamentale ovvero la laringe dove sono
contenute le nostre preziose corde
vocali si appoggia alla colonna stessa
quindi allo scheletro e nel momento in
cui noi iniziamo a suonare le nostre
corde vocali
la vibrazione viene trasmessa le ossa
che essendo cave la trasferiscono in
tutto il corpo e questa si chiama voce
ossea voce interna è molto preziosa per
chi usa la voce a livello professionale
ma per tutti
ecco perché nell'atto cantato si dice
che è tutto il corpo a cantare nell'atto
cantato noi liberiamo le nostre emozioni
come diceva aristotele determina il
canto una catarsi una purificazione
scegliamo le tensioni fisiche del nostro
corpo perché la voce ossea a delle
vibrazioni che sciolgono proprio le
tensioni che abbiamo e ricarichiamo il
nostro cervello di energia grazie alla
proprio a queste frequenze cute che
stimolano proprio lo sviluppo
dell'encefalo bene ci sono poi delle
situazioni particolari che aiutano a
cantare come dicevamo prima sulle
acustiche dei monasteri ce n'è un'altra
che probabilmente conoscete
avete presente il bagno sì il bagno
stimola cantare
questo perché la sua particolarità
ovvero di essere un ambiente riflettente
grazie alle piastrelle determina una
sorta di riverbero naturale in cui le
frequenze sembrano avvolgerci e cantare
diventa più facile per cui vorrei ora
invitarvi a fare un esperimento con memo
forza andiamo tutti in bagno mi sa che
non ce lo lasciano fare
vi chiedo allora cortesemente di unirvi
a un esperimento collettivo con me e di
cantare tutti insieme una canzone
vi chiedo di alzarmi in piedi così avete
la possibilità anche di mettere in
pratica subito questi due consigli
attenzione e postura per fare questo
esperimento abbiamo pensato di
suddividere la platea in quattro cardo e
decumano e allora praticamente ci sono
sei blocchi i primi due blocchi sono
insieme per cui vedete ci sono degli
amici di tex che stanno definendo dove
arriva ad esempio il primo blocco il
secondo blocco è quello più in alto
sotto la galleria il terzo blocco e il
quarto blocco è questo il nostro quinto
blocco è la galleria voi entrerete in
scena dopo e mi raccomando avete un
ruolo a spettacolare per cui abbiate
pazienza che prima inizio a preparare i
nostri musicisti ci state bene
allora volevo assegnare partiamo dal
basso facciamo una canzone siamo proprio
la canzone
partiamo dal basso e il basso lo assegno
al blocco numero 2 perché loro sono
sotto la galleria e quindi hanno una
situazione acustica che favorisce le
note basse e dovete fare così vi prego
di imitarmi un po di coraggio vi prego
se vi riesce difficile come tonalità vi
consiglio di fare l'ottava sopra e
quindi
tu tu tu
tondo
no
quando
tutto
mondo
e a me si può fare di più
ok mi chiedo di ricordarvi la vostra
parte
ora chiederò al nostro primo blocco di
fare la chitarra sempre tre note volete
più facile no però vorrei che la mia
must e la chitarra
ok per cui il risultato è così no questo
non è il risultato
ecco che ti nutri nutrienti nutrienti to
train di tutor indetto trend e renderlo
33 detto trento trento trentino 3
bellissimo to treat utilissimo tool
trendy ok
i bravissimi adesso chiederò al nostro
blocco numero 3 anche voi in galleria di
fare la parte bassa del nostro
pianoforte vocale che fa così
[Musica]
tondo
un buon punto
coach e liberate la voce
[Musica]
grandi grandi
bene ora chiederò alla nostra al nostro
blocco numero 4 di fare la parte più
alta del pianoforte invece sempre due
note come i nostri amici del blocco 3 e
fanno così
[Musica]
si no
bungaro
[Musica]
facciamoci un bell'applauso si ok allora
galleria portate un attimo di pazienza
non vi insegno nulla voi perché la
saprete già fare la parte ma prima
componiamo la nostra musica e quindi
vorrei qui e iniziano le cose difficili
di di mettere insieme i vari blocchi
vi chiedo solo di prestare attenzione a
un certo punto quando partiranno
la nostra galleria vi verrà la
tentazione di seguirli
aspettate un po vi faccio un segnale
faccio vero ve lo dico vi faccio un
segnale di tipo così e dopo di che vi
faccio un altro segnale perché siamo già
in time up e farò così
e tutti quanti concluderemo la nostra
canzone ok quindi il primo segnale
ci uniamo al coro e con questo segnale
chiudiamo ok
bene allora chiedo al nostro blocco
numero due di iniziare con il basso
naturalmente abbiamo nel loop che ci
aiuta a memorizzare la parte ok quindi
era tre note di basso
[Musica]
va bene anche la variante
no
ok io faccio la batteria in veneto
blocco 1 scese pronti con la nostra
chitarra
mi raccomando da posa assolutamente rock
2 notte
però
[Musica]
o c'è
minute
il 4
[Musica]
bravi
mi trovo
[Musica]
ok
quando facciamo che ci uniamo al coro ma
non facciamo un rifiuto
ora libererò la nostra galleria siete
pronti
dovete fare una cosa molto speciale che
fanno
il motivo
no
[Musica]
davanti
no
[Musica]
allora
la madonna
[Musica]
no
la la la la la la la la
[Musica]
[Applauso]
l'avana
la la la la
la la la la la la la la peggio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
bravissimi
quindi liberate la vostra voce è stanco
rock
[Applauso]
meraviglioso il popolo lista dex ed ex
verona è fantastico grazie
[Applauso]